[Music]
yeah my name is John Stouffer I'm a
photographer and a father so my
grandparents lived here for 30 years the
main reason that we moved here was
because of the opportunity that my
grandparents were selling the house
at first I thought it wasn't a good idea
because it was short ceilings there was
carpet everywhere there was carpet in
the bathroom it was carpet in the
kitchen we had to kind of see past all
that and see the potential in the house
and once we were able to do that we got
excited about making it our own I think
older houses are definitely higher
quality it's because it was made for a
specific person or a specific family
that style that craftsmanship has
definitely influenced me it's made me
want to make this house as beautiful and
as high-quality as possible we try to
honor the past in the materials we use
classic materials like metal wood stone
but if you're using these classic
materials it'll be high quality
it'll be hair looking back to design
it's been used for hundreds thousands of
years really what comes through to me is
the most important in my life is doing
life well with my family and my wife and
my daughter and loving everybody around
us and I'd like to think that reflects
and everything that we do